hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the phoenix
grand swiss uh chess.com speedy grand
swiss that's currently being played in
riga latvia it's the second round and
it's nihil sarin vs fabiano caruana a
lot of you guys have requested this one
and for good reason so we're gonna check
it out there are many games being played
of course we can't cover all of them but
i will try to cover as many uh as i can
and well it's just very enjoyable so
let's check it out uh so setting with
the white pieces opens with d4 we have
d5 by fabi c4 e6 knight to c3 and now
the sharp target defense with c5 with e3
knight to f6 and now knight to f3 so
this is all very very standard we have
a6 by fabi and the capture sun d5 e
captures and bishop to e2 so this is
again
all been played many many times uh
knight to c6 and uh
sarin castles we have bishop to d6 and
now we have a trait here making black
waste of tempo so captures captures and
b3 now uh nihal prepares the finca to
his light square bishop now to grab hold
of this long diagonal so castles uh
bishop to b2 and now bishop back to a7
you know the rook the c1 is coming
so the bishop is not very well placed on
c5 and what you really want to do is
play bishop a7 queen d6 bishop b8 and
then put a lot of pressure on white's
king side so this is fabi's plan a very
attacking formation rook to c1 and now
rook to e8 and here uh the
most common move is knight to a4 with uh
with the direct threat of just bishop
captures knight here because if queen
captures then queen capture spawn on d5
that's kind of the idea here and uh you
could play some like this queen d6 we're
going to capture here then black actors
with the g pawn doesn't look all that
impressive for black but you know some
people enjoy it
another thing after knight a4 you could
play knight to e for just get the knight
out of harm's way then white can go back
knight to c3 and then let's say bishop
to e6 and the game just continues uh
this is of course possible but uh sarin
goes for h3 it's a move that's been
played only once uh and a long long time
ago it's uh was played like in 1977 and
uh although it has been reached before
the the move in that game was bishop to
f5 but here fabi goes for a queen to d6
and it is now already as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game five is
now preparing bishop to b8 he's going to
put a lot of pressure on sarin's king
side
and if this knight ever leaves the f3
square could be very dangerous so here
we have bishop to d3
and now comes the bishop to d7 we have
knights to e2 shifting the knights to
help out with the the defense and the
king side but also preparing knights to
d4 to block this bishop and also to
offer some trades so rook a to d8 and
now knight e to d4 uh so knights the e4
by fabi you don't want to trade here
trading here doesn't really do anything
for you for example captures captures
captures and captures and now uh
suddenly we just have a beautifully
placed knight here on d4 you don't have
a c pawn or an e pawn to kick it away
from there it would just be very
enjoyable for white so instead after
knight e to d4 we have knight to e4
saying that all right my knight is now
excellently placed here and if you
capture it then i just bring my rook
into the attack and all is well here so
here we have queen to e2 uh connecting
the rooks uh but now bishop to b8 as
planned and are there any dangers here
so a lot of pieces are attacking that
king side what can you play here well
rook after d1 is one such move because
the knight might move and you really
want to have this f1 square available
for your king
because now ideas like for example
knight to g5 don't really work uh even
though you you now have access to the h2
square if knight is captured on f3 but
we can just play knight captures and c6b
captures and king f1 and you don't
really care uh if knight captures we're
gonna play queen captures and queen h2
doesn't do anything for black we can
even grab a pawn and if queen h1 check
we can just move attack the queen so
this is perfectly fine for white
or or rather it should be uh so after
rook after d1 favi switches the queen
over to the g file queen g6 now the
thread is bishop captures on h3 as the g
point is pinned and now knight the h4
you could also consider maybe some kink
to f1 king the h1 moves setting goes for
queen and knight to h4 and now we have
knight captures on d4 saying okay if you
capture my queen i'm gonna capture your
queen with check and then after bishop
captures h captures i'm going to be up a
knight so of course black would be
completely winning here so after knight
captures on d4 we have bishop captures
on d4 eliminating this knight and now
queen to h6 attacking the knight here so
knight goes back and now a very precise
calculation by fabi bishop captures an
h3 this is the move from the thumbnail
uh and what do you do here well there's
really nothing better than to just
capture the bishop and then hope for the
best so g captures on h3 queen captures
an h3 and now uh what do you play here
it's a really really tough position to
defend and there's only one good move
that saves the white here really
so i'm even gonna ask you to pause the
video and try to find this idea because
it's not an easy one to make so feel
free
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the only
resource that allows you to continue
playing this game and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is of
course queen to f1 you have to attack
black's queen and give up the knight on
f3 it sounds odd so congratulations to
everyone who founded this but uh uh
there's really no other move you can
play here i mean it's just uh it's just
an ugly position this knight can never
move bishop to h2 just the winds on the
spot
and if you try to eliminate something
like rook captures then rook to g4 is
coming so you can't play that there's
really no good way to to play this so
sarin finds the only idea which is queen
to f1 and now fabi just picks up the
knight queen captures on f3 he has the
attack he now equalized the material or
rather the pieces but he's now also up
two pawns so queen to g2 offering a
queen trade and it's not one you can
decline easily because uh well um
checkmate is being threatened on g7 so
fabi trades here captures captures and
now h6 so now we have this end game uh
where fabi's up two pawns but uh sarin
has the bishop pair so maybe it's not
all all lost so here we have b4 he wants
to start advancing on the queen side
and now comes rook to e6 preparing some
checks
via rook to g6 so a4
and now what do you play here well this
is one position where you really really
really have to figure out how to
continue because uh you know uh
one slight inaccuracy and uh it's all
over uh and here you have to decide
between something like a rook to g6
check f5 uh or you know moves like that
or maybe even prepare f5 rook to fade in
f5 but rook the g6 check is very
interesting because it kind of trades
down one of the rooks for example bishop
to h2 we want to play rook to g1 and now
after the
move like rook to c2 we're going to play
rook to g1 check king to e2 we can trade
once here captures capture so now we go
back bishop to d6 and now maybe we start
pushing here so maybe that's um
one of the ways to play this however
fabi played h5 here and this um
kind of allows uh sarin to uh take
advantage of the many uh weaknesses
black has in the position he starts with
rook the c2
and fabi now plays bishop to e5 so this
is his plan he wants to eliminate the
bishop pair or rather one of the bishops
but it also means giving up a control of
the c7 square and sarin very happily
goes for this bishop captures rook
captures and now rook to c7 just putting
pressure on that b7 pawn knight to d6
defending and now bishop back to e2 now
uh putting more pressure on on uh the
the d5 pawn also maybe bishop can come
to f3 to attack the pawn further so rook
to g5 check king to f1 and now rook to
f5 with ideas of maybe knight coming to
e4
so king back to g2 rook to g factor king
to f1 and rook f5 so a repetition is
being offered
but after rook to g2 fabi just advances
his pawn to b5 and here he says all
right let's uh continue playing uh but
now it's much much easier for sarin to
uh
stabilize the position a captures on b5
we have knight captures on b5 uh and now
you have this problem of the pawn on a6
just being extremely weak but also after
rook to c5 what do you play here now as
black yes you're still up material
but there's no easy way to make progress
if either of the rooks move of the
defense of the d5 point we're just gonna
capture it if the knight moves we're
going to capture the a6 pawn if the
knight doesn't move we're going to
capture on b five pawn captures and rook
captures we're going to win upon this
way so there really isn't a good way for
fabi to defend this rook the b8 was
played
and now we have bishop to f1 now bishop
to f1 is a nice uh little uh tricky
improvement in the position because if
you just go up on grabbing here rook
captures we're going to play rook
captures rook captures and on knights
the c3 might be a little bit annoying
attacking the rook and the bishop here
and uh you don't really have a good move
here you even have to give up the bishop
with some like rook captures on h5 if
you try and save the bishop then just
captures captures and captures and now
black is winning he's up two pawns this
is um
an easy win for black
so uh sarin uh sees this he sees that
knight the c34 could be a problem he
just sidesteps with the bishop bishop to
f1 and now he's ready to capture the
pawn so rook g5 checked by fabi king h2
now rook to g4 now that there's nothing
better going after the pawn here but now
sarin just captures on d5 but not with
this rook with this rook we have rook
captures on v4 and now even rook
captures an h5 so you can see that that
h5 push um
well got fabi into more trouble then
than it really did anything for for his
position so g6 we have rook h back to d5
and now king to g7 king to g3 fabi's
still up upon but how is this pawn ever
going forward i mean you can't move the
pawn because then you lose the knight
it's being attacked three times if you
move the knight you lose the pawn uh so
really really impossible and even if you
could somehow do it again if you
successfully move the knight you can
never push the pawn both of the rooks
control the a5 square so that pawn is
not moving an inch so rook to be six by
five bishop to d3 we have rook to b2 and
now we have f3 we have rook to b3 e for
now uh rook to d6 now going for this uh
final trick in the position and it's not
uh
not all that obvious but of course sarin
doesn't fall for it the idea is if the
rook is captured then we're gonna play
knight captures on d6 and of course if
you grab the pawn then knight captures
an e4 check wins for black because the
pawn is pinned and you're just gonna
blunder a rook so of course this is
fabi's last attempt uh sarin of course
sees this he just captures on b5 removes
the defender of the rook on d6 and now
you can't go for this because of course
just this so we have to play rook
captures on d3 and now rook captures on
d3 rook captures on d3 and rook to b6
attacking the pawn here so fabi advances
it and now rook to a6 and now sarin has
a passport uh behind um
behind
the
well he has a rook behind the pass pawn
we have rook to a3 defending it but it's
not really anything uh special so here
we have e5 uh a4 advancing the pawn but
not rook to a7 we have king to f8 uh
king to g4 and now rook to e3 going
after this pawn trying to trade this
pawn for this pawn but just king f4 we
have rooked a3 king to g4 rook to e3 and
now king to f4
rook to a3 king to g4 and he was in this
position on move 57 that nihal and uh
fabiano agreed to a draw as there is
nothing more to be done here so really a
crazy game it took a very interesting
turn very early on in the game already
as of move 13 we had a completely new
game then fabi's sacrificed for the
attack and uh
sarin really had to give up that uh
bishop here after bishop captures like
there was really nothing other than
queen to f1 you have to give up the
knight and then he is up to pawns but as
you can see uh it's not that easy to
convert to this even for a former 2800
player like fabiano caruana and i say
former because in the previous video uh
where i've shown fabi's game i told you
guys that he was back
on 2800 uh that's not really true uh he
is still at 2800 because of course
ratings change once a month but on the
live ratings list he's below 2800 i
don't know why i thought that he'd be
again 2800 after winning like one game
here in this tournament he he's not far
behind like maybe if he gets like three
wins in a row he could climb back uh but
uh for the moment he is not you know uh
serves me right for trusting certain
people on twitter uh but yeah so sorry
about that i did not mean to deceive you
on on on purpose uh so really a
wonderful game excellent uh defending by
sarin from that difficult position and
well it really shows you just how uh
promising of uh uh of an elite player a
young nihal is
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to wish a
very happy birthday to allison and i
would like to thank michael kennedy
gustavo fernandez thc ollie.nl and
george norsworthy for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh to cover some other games
from this wonderful event checking up on
your wonderful suggestions and well
whatever else happens in the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day